rapporteur spécial de la commission des
finances pour 5 minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances monsieur le rapporteur
général mes chers collègues comme chaque
année l'examen du prélèvement sur
recette au profit de l'Union européenne
est un exercice complexe car aussitôt le
projet de loi de finance déposée le
montant prévisionnel inscrit dans le
texte est dépassé la lecture et on est
particulièrement brouillée de la mesure
où le budget de l'Union européenne pour
2022 déjà modifié par quatre budgets
rectificatifs a fait l'objet d'un nouvel
ajustement postérieurement au dépôt du
projet de loi de finances la Commission
européenne a parallèlement présenté une
lettre rectificative au projet de budget
de l'Union pour 2023 alors que le
dialogue avec le Conseil et le Parlement
européen autour de son adoption était
déjà engagée il est vrai que ces
modifications sont liées à une nouvelle
crise systémique liée à l'agression
russe en Ukraine et à ses conséquences
notamment en termes d'inflation et
d'accès à l'énergie ce contexte ne
pouvait évidemment pas
si au contraire comme semble laisser
penser la résolution du Parlement
européen examiner ce jour l'accroisement
des dépenses liées notamment aux
contrecoup de la guerre en Ukraine va
conduire à augmenter le budget de
l'Union et par conséquent la
participation de la France à son
financement
au-delà de l'évolution de l'évaluation
de prélèvement sur recette proprement
dit la commission des finances s'est
préoccupé des conséquences du retard
apporté à la définition de nouvelles
ressources propres le dépôt d'un rapport
d'étape est la première des libération
du Conseil echofines sous président
françaises ne constitue que l'amorce
d'un processus qui prend déjà du retard
madame la ministre un mécanisme
d'ajustement carbone aux frontières
sera-t-il effectivement définie d'ici à
la fin de l'année au demeurant si trois
pistes différentes de ressources
nouvelles sont sur la table des
négociations leur montant global
même pose question il est en effet
inférieur au total des dépenses qu'elles
sont censées financer remboursement des
fonds empruntés pour abonder la facilité
pour la reprise et la résilience mise en
oeuvre du Fond Social pour le climat et
désormais création du ripower you
c'est un sujet que nous ne pouvons
ignorer faute de quoi le budget national
serait appelé à contribuer à hauteur de
2,5 milliards d'euros environ
remboursement des dettes contractées par
la commission au nom de l'Union sans
compter les nouvelles garanties
susceptibles d'être raccorder tel
figurant à l'article 37 quaters du
projet de loi de finances au titre des
des prêts que l'Union accorde à
l'Ukraine au vu des engagements déjà
pris et des évolutions en cours il
serait utile de disposer d'un état
précis des sommes que la France est
susceptible d'être appelé à importer à
l'Union à moyen et long terme au-delà du
prélèvement sur recette
parallèlement aux dépenses classiques
généralement au désigné comme des
retours la France est l'un des
principaux bénéficiaires au montant si
ce n'est en pourcentage du revenu
national de la facilité pour la reprise
et la résilience crée dans le cadre de
la réponse de l'Union à la pandémie next
generation ou je me félicite que la
France ait été très peu de temps après
l'Espagne le deuxième pays a présenté un
plan national puise à bénéficier d'un
prêt financement ainsi que d'un premier
montant de subvention en revanche je
voudrais souligner l'ajustement par la
Commission européenne passer inaperçue à
la veille de l'été des allocations
nationales liées à une croissance plus
forte que celle attendue c'est un
justement c'est traduit par une baisse
d'1,9 milliards d'euros de la dotation
prévue au total la France recevra donc
37,5 milliards d'euros au lieu des 39,4
attendus
je serai preneur si vous en disposez
d'éléments sur la façon dont
s'effectuera l'ajustement des versement
reçu par la France en conclusion mes
chers collègues lors de l'examen de
l'article 25 de la commission le 2
novembre la commission des Finances
avait proposé son adoption sans
modification je vous indique par avance
qu'elle a décidé de donner un avis
favorable à l'adoption de l'amendements
du gouvernement qui modifie le montant
du prélèvement sur recettes initialement
inscrit au projet de loi de finances
cette ajustement technique c'est la
dernière phrase à généralement lieu en
nouvelle lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
l'adoption du budget de l'Union par le
Parlement européenne lundi dernier a
permis que le Sénat se prenant sur
l'évaluation révisée du prélèvement ce
dont je me félicite pour la clarté de
nos débats
merci monsieur le rapporteur
non pas du tout il y a pas de souci
Monsieur Jean-François rap